come
[Musica]
[Applauso]
pres
[Musica]
così cos destra sinistra
[Applauso]
destra e oggi maestre contro
alunni le maestre si sfideranno in una
serie di scherzi con contro gli alunni e
chi vincerà questa guerra degli scherzi
vincerà il mio nuovissimo libro La città
stregata che è ora disponibile in
libreria e on Se non ce l'avete ancora
cos state aspettando andate subito a
prenderlo e vi lascio qua un messaggio
segreto che potrete tradurre con
l'alfabeto segreto che c'è all'interno
del libro Questo è il vostro messaggio
traduc telo poi Inviatemi un messaggio
su Instagram con la traduzione del
messaggio e Vi saluterò ma ora iniziamo
subito con la prima lezione e i primi
scherzi alla maestra Pronti
[Musica]
Via
Buongiorno
Allora mettiamo subito le cose in chiaro
non mi è piaciuto l'atteggiamento delle
ultime volte quindi Da oggi chi si azaa
a fare uno scherzo da fuori
capito Gli facciamo tanti scherzi Sì sì
sì ne sto già preparando uno Anzi che mi
fa un solo scherzo viene
bocciato fuori dall'auto eraa scuola
Voglio vedere
eh iniziamo la lezione Allora
Dammela facciamo uno scherzo
questo mente bellissimo anche
io
allora oggi Vediamo le
frazioni
maestra
[Musica]
sì bravissimo ma sì professore Ma cosa
vi ha
[Musica]
detto
le frazioni Allora dovete sapere stiamo
parlando di un'epoca in cui le frazioni
ancora non esistevano E isela cosa
decise di fare decise di
murire du qu Questo è il mio momento è
il momento di plia il bullo E oggi ho la
cacca telecomandata la faccio ballare io
la maestra adesso fa uno du e è
[Musica]
[Applauso]
così ragazzi siete pronti Sì
sì E allora
Ah santantonio da Paloma
santambrogio aiuto
[Applauso]
Sì sei stato
Gi ma ma
Sea tei
par
ma si
calmi da preside
preside povero
Billy Riposa in pace È stato bello
conoscerti
Fly R vendicherò Io bly mi metterò il
bullo 9 della scuola e f tutti quanti
gli scherzi alla maestra Santina Ora sto
preparando io uno scherzo per
Santina le attaccherò un biglietto
bellissimo nella
schiena mentre Santina non c'è posso
andare con il mio Scherzo non ne avevo
mai fatto uno sono troppo
felice
[Musica]
Sh
è meno un uno è sistemato Voglio vedere
chi è il prossimo
Eh
[Musica]
allora A
me
me scrivete è quello che più ved la E
[Musica]
silen allora Allora 12 con
X vuol dire che
21 è diverso da y se noi scriviamo X
Yi
[Musica]
ma ma
cos adesso mi agate
[Applauso]
Veramente sono Miata amente signor PR
signora Santina si calmi Mi dica cosa è
successo eh mi calmo continuano a fare
gli schetch gli guardi che ver dica
qualcosa ma come si sono
permessi Non si preoccupi signora
Santina me ne occupo io adesso le vada
vada vada riamo tutto oh così va bene
vado Grazie Meno male c' lei guard
venite qua subito Ma come vi siete
permessi veramente non si fa una cosa
del genere se professore Santino una
persona importante Ma come Non vi
vergognate ma dico è andata via è uscita
È uscita Avete fatto bene Siete stati
bravis non la posso vedere qu è proprio
una rompiscatole adesso sapete cosa fa
lei non ci vorrà più venire a scuola Sì
E purtroppo dobbiamo prendere una
supplente e la dobbiamo prendere adesso
però brav Bravi fate finta uscite dalla
classe tutti tristi Fate finta che vi ho
sgridati e andate che c'è la supplente
che vi aspetta Mi raccomando Fatela Brai
Eh però tanto se n'è
andata Siamo troppo forti Grand andate
dai Andate Andate piano piano piano
anche tu Grazie grazie grazie presidente
ciao ciao eh non lo fate più eh mi
raccomando
Ah Voi siete ancora qua Eh allora
ricordate di cliccare mi piace e
iscrivervi al canale altrimenti vi mando
signora Santina anche a casa vostra eh
attenti
[Applauso]
vemo noi possiamo fare quello che
vogliamo Guardate guardate questa questa
Ditemi chi sembro chi sembro E allora
dovete fare una brav e i compiti per le
vacanze dovete f i
compiti lo so io lo so io lo so io è
spider-man Ma come spider-man Ma cosa
centro Io lo so la maestra Santina che
sta invitando È vero maestra
Santin Dai facci vedere Facci
vedere maestra sentina mi piace la
cacca Che c'è Che c'è Che c'è Che c'è e
che
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che Ma questa maestra è
cattivissima povero Billy Vabbè era un
bullo un po' gli sta bene eh
diciamo sì ah sì Adesso sono io pli
Bullo Anzi Franky
Bullo Ma
smettila Hai fatto bene Eh lo so
Eh io sono la supplente regina e dato
che sono una supplente e non una maestra
a me di voi non me ne frega niente
potete anche schiattare Ma a me non
[Musica]
interessa il nuovo libro di Anita
questo lo prendo e me lo leggo
Io bene in quanto a voi vi do un compito
dovete scrivere 100 volte sono stupido
Anzi V scriv la
[Musica]
bagna forza
iniziate
[Musica]
il mio Tessaro mio solamente mio tutto
mio non vedo orora di leggerlo
tutto Ma come ci ha preso il libro
dovevamo vincerlo noi nella Challenge
professori contro alunni Ecco noi
volevamo vincere Uffa questo questo
cagnolino mi ha rubato il posto Uffa era
il mio Poo questo e mi spad pure in
faccia ma guarda che proprio è il
malanza più bello che ho mai visto è
Merlino ma è Merlino può fare il nostro
nuovo compagno effetti ma c'è tempo da
perdere Mi è venuta un'idea il libro
potremo rubarglielo
Ho un piano Allora secondo me Doo fare
così con
[Musica]
questa
bellissimo Ma secondo te se ne accorgerà
no se ne accorgerà è listata da libro di
Anita è talmente interessante che non si
rende conto degli scherzi hai
ragione è bellissimo C'è anche un
alfabeto
[Musica]
segreto
ma le scarpe dove sono Non ci
sono pensavate di avermi fregata
eh
e ora il colpo
[Musica]
finale Mi sa proprio che questa lezione
l'ha vinta la
maestra Fai così fai così destra
[Applauso]
sinistra
Oddio Aspetta ti aiuto Ioa Challenge
scuola nella vita reale
secchioni contro
Bulli Chi vincerà la Challenge vincerà
il mio nuovissimo libro La città
stregata agli investigatori del mistero
che è ora disponibile on in tutte le
librerie voi ce l'avete Se non ce
l'avete andate subito a prenderlo e mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
iniziamo subito la
Challenge Io sono Lidia e la mia abilità
è imparare tutto quello che
[Musica]
leggo Io sono Anita e faccio parte del
team dei
secchioni e la mia abilità è risolvere i
misteri come nel nuovo libro in cui c'è
un nuovissimo mistero da risolvere voi
potete provare a risolverlo insieme a
noi infatti Se non ce l'avete andate
subito a prenderlo e dentro c'è anche
l'alfabeto segreto ma ora il libro lo
vincerà solo chi vincerà questa
Challenge Infatti verrà custodito nella
prigione di massima sicurezza e chiunque
si avvicinerà riceverà una scossa da
1000 vol Io sono gny so fare benissimo
il calcoli della Matematica per esempio
1 + 1 2 Ovviamente faccio parte del team
dei secchi
occhioni
[Musica]
Eccomi io sono Billy del team dei bulli
e anche oggi farò scappare tutti i
secchioni Io sono Jack del Zin dei bulli
e anche se sono un po' stupido faccio
degli scherzi
indimenticabili io sono Frank del team
dei Bull e posso far sparire qualsiasi
cosa come i compiti dei
secchioni
Oh no mi fanno paura Uffa Eccoli tornati
i bulli no i miei compiti No sono quello
che t tengo di più Allora io mi siedo
Qui ci
sta Allora ragazzi siamo Pronti
prontissimi un altro giorno di scherzi
arrivato
sìì si sente proprio che sono arrivati i
bulli state facendo troppo casino
ragazzi miei Oggi è la giornata perfetta
per fare un sacco di scherzi divertenti
quello che ci piace
fare ma insomma fate silenzio dobbiamo
studiare noi dobbiamo
[Musica]
concentrarci la verifica Sì siamo
prontissimi per perché noi siamo i
secchioni abbiamo studiato tantissimo lo
vinceremo noi il libro e già il
nostro ci siamo troppo
forti Ehi Ma ragazzi come facciamo a
fare la verifica io c'ho solo la penna
Io sono la gma Io sono il quaderno ma
perché questo quaderno È Rosa Tu sei un
bullo ma di tre non ne facciamo uno non
so neanche scrivere io oh neanche io St
scrivere
brav tu sei scrivere
No ragazzi Ragazzi ma se andassimo a
fare degli scherzi ai secchioni
D'altronde è la nostra
specialità siamo già 3 minuti in classe
non abbiamo ancora fatto uno scherzo
andiamo andiamo guare
subito fa i bulli stanno facendo troppo
rumore non riesco a concentrarmi basta
per favore come si fa a fare una
verifica così e così
Guarda
questo sei
brutto
fantastico vè Vabbè ma non dobbiamo fare
gli scherzi fra di noi dobbiamo farli a
loro ai secchioni Sì ho un'idea perché
non andiamo nell'altra classe Sì avete
ragione Andiamocene
Addio Bulli noi ce ne andiamo perché
fate troppo rumore Ciao
Ragazzi abbiamo fatta media ai secchioni
Sì la classe è
nostra tempo abbiamo più tempo per
organizzare i nostri scherzi Oh tiriamo
fuori tutti i nostri giochetti e poi
andiamo dalle
secchione Mi è venuta un'idea il mio
topo non è un topo normale è un topo
telecomandato e quindi lo potrei mandare
dalle secchio a sciare i loro compiti
con i suoi occhietti e magari anche a
farle spaventare Oh fantastico
[Applauso]
brav Che schifo paura chei Pens se
chiode siamo i più fig della
scuola ragazze Lo sentite il silenzio Sì
finalmente Adesso sì che possiamo
concentrarci sul tema Senza quei Bulli
non vedo là di avere quel libro in
[Musica]
mano erano proprio insopportabili Eh sì
noi dobbiamo vincere dobbiamo vincerlo
noi il libro
assolutamente bene Ragazzi allora con
quale scherzo iniziamo a terrorizzare i
secchioni Io ho un pipistrello finto
possiamo farle spaventare
tantissimo fantastico e tu quale scherzo
hai Io ho la cacca No fantastico
mitico No ragazzi oggi vi stupirò io
guardate cosa ho un topo telecomandato è
belliss posto degli occhi alle
telecamere fantastico In questo modo
possiamo copiare i compiti delle
secchione e vinceremo il libro il libro
di Anita Sì dai ragazzi ce la possiamo
fare andiamo
andiamo guida guida così poi io scrivo
qua quello che am vai così vai
così destra destra destra sì io son
pronto dai Ok Fai così occhio Così ti
sbatti così ti
sbatti non ti sbatti
S che scho Che
scho c'o c'o oken veloci attenzione
Adesso cerca di farlo salire dobbiamo
riuscire a inquadrare il compito per poi
ricopiarlo scrivo tutto qua dai dai dai
orola su Sì bravo
[Applauso]
avanti Eccoci siamo arrivati si CR Vai
vai verifica di italiano Sema a piacere
cos diciamo E
ma Ah ma è finto è
finto
[Musica]
sono stati Bulli ci stanno
scoprendo indietro indietro tirata siamo
dai Bulli Come vi siete permessi Bulli a
farci questo scherzo Siete dei
grandissimi rispettosi e noi noi noi non
abbiamo fatto niente fatto la maestra e
poi chi se ne frega del compito tanto il
libro lo vinceremo noi ci avete
distratto dal compito adesso come
facciamo sì e dobbiamo vincere noi il
libro non voi Voi non ve lo meritate
poch non ce lo meritiamo noi il libro
Noi siamo i più fighi di questa scola
non vinceremo sicuramente
noi Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita sono qua
per ricordarvi che appena è uscito il
mio nuovo libro La città
stregata Se non ce l'avete Ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno il regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo tanti messaggi assieme
prendetelo subito eh sì
dicevamo il libro lo vincerete voi
[Musica]
cer
Noi siamo le più
brave e infatti ora ce ne torniamo a
scrivere il tema Così noi potremmo
vincere il
libro stanno arrivando Mi devo
[Musica]
nascondere cos'è
stato
pulsanti
scorregge sono stati Bulli ci hanno
fregato di nuovo un altro scherzo dei
[Musica]
bulli Ora basta Dobbiamo finire il
nostro tema
[Musica]
Ok qu è
quello
No non toccarlo Che schifo Magari porta
le
malattie anche questo è finto Sì sono
stati
Bulli
Eccolo il libro Dev essere nostro
iniziamo a scassinare Allora tu vai giù
vai giù vai
[Musica]
giù si apre
mi è venuta
unidea un topo ma ci serve una chiave
non un topo stai a
vedere Ah oh Ma come hai fatto Laia del
topo funziona
[Musica]
sempre fto adesso prendiamo il libro Sì
il libro è nostro ragazzi Il libro è
nostro Dobbiamo prenderlo il libro di
Anita tiralo fuori tiralo fuori piano
piano piano questo è prezioso
bellissim abbiamo vinto noi è bellissimo
ed è
nostro Ora basta Noi abbiamo scritto il
nostro tema quindi andiamo a prenderci
il libro Sì
[Musica]
esatto Come vi siete permessi avete
rubato il libro è ingiusto Ma chi se ne
frega Tanto il libro ce l'abbiamo
comunque noi ce l'abbiamo
noi abbiamo vinto TIM Bully Vince non
avete neanche scritto il tema non potete
prendere il libro voi lo avete
rubato Ma non avete toccato le sbarre se
voi toccate le sbarre avrete altri 10
libri sì sì sì è vero Sì vi basta
toccare le sbarre per avere altri 10
libri come 10
libri
spens io
ragazzi Oddio Aspetta Ti aiuto
io buttiamoli
[Musica]
dentro abbiamo preso noi libro abbiamo
vinto noi Team secchioni
siamoi
Siamo troppo
forti che schifo Adesso vi faccio vedere
io che cosa significa disturbare Tutto
il giorno nuovissimo Challenge
Bulli contro
popolari contro
secchii mi scola Ciao io sono Charlot e
io sono William E noi siamo i più
popolari della scuola D'altronde veniamo
da due famiglie ricchissime Anzi adesso
arriva il papi con la Porsche Aspetta io
sono più popolare
[Musica]
selfie e noi siamo Anita e Julie Team
secchione Sì quando mi arrabbio non si
salva nessuno quindi state attenti E a
me piace tantissimo leggere e scrivere e
infatti ho qua con me il mio nuovissimo
libro La città stregata agli
investigatori del intero è appena uscito
in tutte le librerie onl Mi raccomando
andate a prenderlo anche voi e questo è
il premio finale di chi vince la
Challenge vincere la Challenge il più
bravo a scuola e ora lo custodiamo qua
al
sicuro Io sono Billy il bullo E io sono
Frank del team dei bulli Noi siamo del
team dei bulli e ovviamente io sono il
capo Scusa no sono io il capo No ma come
tu il capo sei così basso sono io il
capo sono io capo
per poter vincere la Challenge dobbiamo
studiare tanto sì Iniziamo ma tanto a
noi piace un sacco studiare quindi siamo
qua in libreria e iniziamo a leggere
qualche libro vediamo se ci aiuta Ehi
ciao sono l'emoji di Anita e è un gioco
per te Prova a lasciare mi piace entro 5
secondi 5 4 3 2 1 tempo scaduto ci sei
riuscita allora vediamo un po' questo
[Musica]
libro c'è la cacca che schifo che schifo
che schifo guarda ho trovato la
cell che cosa Ma è uno scherzo Chi è
[Applauso]
stato un altro il bante con la
scorra questi scherzi mi ricordano
qualcuno ho messo in tutti i libri Macca
ma Macca guarda guarda guarda che
schifo Ma cosa Saranno stati Bulli
sicuramente
Uffa Che cos'è questo non possiamo
studiare Adesso hanno nascosto degli
scherzi in ogni libro andiamo da
un'altra
parte Siamo troppo forti sono i più
belli di tutto il mondo esatto ma tanto
noi che ce ne frega delle Challenge
tanto poi il libro lo R Sì lo dobbiamo
rubare Però secondo me gli scherzi li
meriterebbero anche i popolari andiamo a
vedere cosa stanno faccendo i popolari
Eh i secchioni facciamo gli scherzi a
tutti
andiamo forza William vieni a fare il
selfie Certo che è difficile essere così
popolari A chi lo dici tutti che ti
fermano e ti chiedono foto è veramente
impossibile Beh di certo non sei
Popolare quanto me Cosa vuoi saperne
occh non rimanere accecata con la mia
penna d'oro Sai cosa ci renderebbe
veramente popolari Che cosa il libro di
Anita Sì con quello guadagneremo un
sacco di follower Sì cavolo immaginati
noi due e la foto con il libro al centro
sarebbe fantastico Allora impegniamoci
facciamo i compiti così possiamo vincere
il
libro troppo
semplice
basta Io ho finito io non ho più voglia
diretta No
direi ma chi ci ha conciati così lo
sogliamo subito questa
cosa Adesso perderemo tutti i nostri po
Già me lo immagino una carriera rovinata
dobbiamo per forza vincere quel libro
per recuperare tutti i nostri finiamo in
fretta
Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita sono qua per
ricordarvi che è appena uscito oggi il
mio nuovo libro La città
stregata Se non ce l'avete ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno il regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo tanti messaggi assieme
prendetelo subito
devo sbrigarmi per questo tema devo
scrivere almeno 45 pagine solo 45 io ne
scriverò
150 così tante ma allora io ne devo
scrivere di più se voglio vincere il mio
libro La città sgata io devo
assolutamente vincerlo È troppo bello
voglio averlo tanto lo vinco
[Musica]
io
un
dizionario diio mi aiuterà un sacco per
il tema che sta scrivendo anche a me
devo averlo
subito no lo prendo prima io
mio Dai lascialo a me No lo voglio io ma
mi serve per il tema e anche a me Se è
per questo Dai allora facciamo così ce
lo dividiamo prima io però eh Va bene
dai prima tu
Dov'è finita la mia penna
Eh che
schifo questa non era la penna che avevo
io
prima ma c'è una cacca sono stati Bulli
sicuramente proviamo scrivere con queste
almeno che scho
hanno l'inchiostro puzzolente Ma
dobbiamo comunque continuare il tema
perché dobbiamo vincere il
[Musica]
libro Siamo troppo
forti # troppo imbarazzante # odiamo i
bulli # disagio Aggiungi Ma come si
permettono a noi più popolari che poi
Ripensandoci il libro potremmo meritar
celo naturalmente siamo i più conosciuti
la scuola Esatto ci spetta per diritto
dovremmo andare Daita e farcelo dare lì
Hai perfettamente ragione andiamo
forza fai quello che faccio io Ciao cara
che cosa deve essere l'odore dell'imp
poopolaritàpoopolarità
[Musica]
sei brava sei famosa come
noi Che dici se ce lo fai avere
gratuitamente ovviamente ma come lo
sapete che per avere il mio libro La
città stregata dobbiamo vincere la
Challenge solo il vincitore potrà avere
il libro eh Ma noi ci abbiamo provato ma
ci hanno boicottato in tutti i modi noi
popolari Penso che a noi spetti di
diritto oltretutto Beh anche a noi Bulli
Hanno fatto degli scherzi però stiamo
comunque continuando a scrivere il tema
quindi mi dispiace ma solo chi vincerà
la Challenge vincerà il libro Ma guarda
che secchiona questa che sta continuando
a fare i compiti davanti a noi popolari
non si è permessa neanche di
salutarci Patetica che secchiona che
antipatici questi popolari Mi dispiace
ma come vi ho già detto solamente Chi
vincerà la Challenge potrà vincere
il il libro non non c'è più Ma dov'è
siete stati voi a rubarlo No
assolutamente non faremo ma è una cosa
del genere e poi con tutto il patrimonio
che abbiamo potremmo
comprarcasa
se ci vedessero rubare il libro poi
ciere bero tutti quanti follower persi
No no no allora se non siete stati voi
sei stata tu a rubare il libro No io sto
facendo il mio
testo vero Lei non si è mai distratta
dal tema Ma allora sapete chi
rimane devono essere per forza loro i
bulli S andiamo subito a cercarli Sì
presto
Ah non ce la faccio più e basta voglio
solamente fare il mio
testo Beh a quanto pare questo si è
trasformato in un altro mistero da
risolvere proprio come nel mio libro La
città stregata infatti nel mio libro c'è
un grandissimo mistero da risolvere che
potete provare a risolvere proprio voi
Infatti se non ce l'avete ancora andate
a prenderlo leggetelo e Provate a
risolvere il mistero e All'interno c'è
anche un alfabeto segreto ma è facile
capire chi è stato a rubare il libro
mancano solo loro all'appello i bulli
Esatto andiamo subito a cercarli Aspetta
faccio una diretta così pranno tutti che
sono stati loro recupereremo tutti i
nostri follower così Ok andiamo Ah È
bellissimo questo libro possiamo già
risolvere il mistero lo voglio leggere
tutto questi di lào ancora quelli stanno
ancora studiando scrivendo il tema e noi
ce l'abbiamo già il
libro ma è l'alfabeto segreto no È
incredibile pensi a quello che sto
pensando io possiamo bruciare la scuola
ma che cosa stai dicendo Con questo
alfabeto Noi ora possiamo comunicare
senza che la maestra sappia che cosa
abbiamo scritto
genio e questa è una frase per voi con
il libro potrete tradurla e vi consiglio
di farlo per perché è una bella dedica
per
voi
Vai lo sapevo che eravate state voi a
rubare il libro Sì siamo stati noi ma
col cavolo che ve lo
ridiamo no dovete ridar celo subito
invece perché lo avete rubato non è
vostro vi devo dire che eravamo in
diretta e tutto il mondo Adesso lo sa
cari follower avete sentito qui davanti
abbiamo degli Imp che hanno rubato il
libro adesso i nostri milioni di
follower sapranno quello che avete fatto
Siete voi i cattivi Esatto quindi ridate
celo
subito che paura i
follower piango piango sono un secchione
sono
[Musica]
popolare Ora
basta 149 pagine
149 una me ne mancava per vincere tutto
e avrei potuto vincere il libro Ma no
voi dovevate disturbare e ancora
disturbare non ce la faccio più adesso
vi faccio vedere io che cosa significa
disturbare Tutto il
[Musica]
giorno venite qua così imparate a fare i
Boom Abbiamo recuperato il libro ma chi
ha vinto la Challenge Allora forse noi
siamo i più famosi no ha vinto la
Challenge la persona che ha scritto più
pagine nel tema e quindi Julie Sì lei ha
scritto un sacco di pagine hai vinto il
libro Hai vinto la Challenge lo sapevo
che avrei vinto Ehi e voi se ancora non
avete il mio libro La città stregata è
ora disponibile onl in tutte le librerie
correte subito a prenderlo Sì ho vinto
Ho vinto Ho
vino
C